Google Cloud updates we're not talking
about what's happening now we're talking
about what's happening next you've saved
the date you've registered and now next
2023 is just around the corner all
that's left is to pack your suitcase and
your agenda with our course catalog
we've got nearly 500 sessions that you
can filter by category learning track
level and Industry kicking things off
alphabetically with AI be sure to check
out our opening keynote to learn more
about the new way to Cloud including
more features more types of users and
more fun and do you want your legacy to
extend beyond Legacy apps then make sure
to add the developer keynote to your
agenda for demos use cases and more and
if you're looking to enrich all parts of
your Enterprise be sure to check out our
Dei keynote with our chief diversity
officer and other leaders as they
discuss Equity 2.0 let us know what
you're most excited about in the
comments because with this